Leute ich habe so einen kranken prank so
eine kranke Idee ich werde aber nicht
sagen und es wird auch ein prank sein
bei dem Sandra selber Teil davon ist
also Leute der prank beinhaltet Redstone
und einen Schalter und TNT und dann
wisst ihr glaube ich schon um was es
geht das Handy erstmal was ich gerade
als Bürgermeister von Los Lukas hier
beschlossen habe
oder ich checks nicht mehr ich werde den
ganzen Tag angerufen wer ist das man
sieht doch dein Minecraft Namen hier die
ganze Zeit im Spiel aber du musst halt
dieses Minecraft anrufen ausmachen
schwöre es dir jetzt legt mich Hacker 0
8 11 99 oder so ein ich
bleibe angerufen oder ist das Skype
vielleicht Minecraft
Windows da bist Du angerufen
ist das gerade der Fall bei dir
jetzt mal ganz kurz ran ja geh mal dran
das will ich auch hören dann leg mal
hier auf das hören
[Musik]
Leute ich werde jetzt mal eben fixieren
den den prank vorbereiten und zwar ist
der Plan wir setzen nämlich TNT
[Musik]
hierhin
und werden das jetzt
verbinden
über Redstone werde das jetzt
unterirdisch verbinden so dass sie
selber einen Schalter drücken ich sag da
passiert was dann drückt sie den
Schalter und das einzige was passiert
ist das bei ihr eine Bombe hoch geht das
heißt die prankt sich quasi selber und
sie springt auch selber nicht
ich habe hier einen Schalter gemacht
weil es gibt in Minecraft sowas das
nennt sich Feuerwerk die man hier hin
hier wo ich gerade bin von hier dass du
auch quasi drin Haus so mäßig sehen
kannst und dann drück mal den Schalter
und dann guck mal dein Haus an
[Musik]
nichtsal
[Gelächter]
das war was dickes Essen Leute und man
Inventar auffüllen ich habe mich gar
nichts mehr erschießt mich dann warum
schießt du mich
denn
was ich sagen wollte ist dass ich als
allererstes die wichtigsten Sachen die
wir haben jetzt erstmal verstecken
werden und damit keiner weiß wo ich die
Sachen Verstecke
nicht mal ihr könnt jetzt Spoilern nur
wenige Minuten später ach nee Sandy
hey mein schöner Stall warum macht man
sowas ja das Handy dann fasst du mir
doch mal zusammen was ich gemacht habe
du hast mich hat zahlreiche Male
geschlagen heute ich würde sagen
mindestens 100 mal ja verdient ganz klar
ja ist so junge ich habe dir sogar den
Creative Modus gegeben
führt du bestimmt wann ich
den Bus machen darf und nicht möchtest
du auch mal OP Recht haben ja okay ab
jetzt bist du auch okay
ein anderes deutlich mehr
hey ich konnte mein Arschgesicht man
eine Chance bitte eine allerletzt dicker
alles ist hier voll mit Tieren ich
könnte kotzen mann das war so eine
heiden
[Musik]
komplett aus
oder das ist doch nicht mehr normal ich
meine schaut euch das mal an das eine
Schwein ist hier das anders deutlich
näher am Eingang ich laufe jetzt direkt
rein wenn ich mich jetzt umdrehen und
die stehen da wieder zu zweit dann werde
ich diese Schweine töten
[Musik]
du kannst dir das doch alles nicht mehr
aufwecken oder
stehen zwei Schweine ich wollte die
Schweine töten nicht dich auf einmal
läufst du mir eine Klinge ich wusste
dass es dich am allermeisten provoziert
wird werde ich Unordnung in deinem Leben
reinbringe
danke Gaming for you für
oh mein Gott Leute aus wie vielen habe
ich gerade aus vier Eiern 5 Hühner
rausbekommen kann das einer Klippen ich
weiß ja Basti gerade live ist kann das
einer Basti schicken und fragen was die
Chance dafür ist guck mal wer da nein
jetzt ist ultimate werden Leute es ist
jetzt auch komplett egal wir haben nur
noch 40 Minuten die Kröte springt ja
auch um ich werde jetzt
die Tiere einfangen und dann machen wir
dann nächste Folge den Stall hier
schreibt jemand
ihren Mann
[Applaus]
siriushaus
[Musik]
ich kann mir nicht vorstellen dass das
ganze funktioniert
[Musik]
gut mein Fehler ja klappt leider nicht
Leute wir brauchen behutsamkeitsbuch was
[Musik]
was
Behutsamkeit
warum
Zungenbrecher beruhthaltsam cool keine
Ahnung was brauche ich Brutzeit
was brauche
sprechen ein behutsamkeitsbuch hier ich
habe den Chat geschrieben
ich habe kein Bock weißt du was heute
richtig lachkick ist Luca ich habe heute
die Terrassenböden bestellt ne weil also
wo man es halt bestellt bei einem wie
nennt man das denn noch mal wie so ein
Fliesen Ding keine Ahnung wie man das
nennt ne die schreibt mir in die Mail du
kackst in die Hose jetzt ne die schreibt
mir in die Mail hier die
Auftragsbestätigung pS Ich feier deine
tiktoks nein ja
[Musik]
ich kann sie nicht den Namen sagen ich
kann dir gleich äh soll ich dir die Mail
immer weiterleiten nee wer gefragt hat
ich bin noch so ein Idiot weißt du was
gemacht habe ich habe aus Versehen meine
Spitzhacke gemacht und ich eine Schaufel
[Musik]
Lukas hör dich nicht
wirklich oder prankst du nicht ich
schwöre ich höre dich nicht ich höre
aber auch kein Minecraft Ton gerade ihr
habt ihr den minecraft-, ich glaube du
hast einfach dein PC auf lautlos
[Musik]
hörst du mich Sandy ich bin sehr lautlos
hörst du mich ja ich habe dich die ganze
Zeit gehört
die ganze Zeit von irgend so ein paar
free wifi angerufen wie kann ich den
löschen Freunde 4 wenn du in Minecraft
bist nein jetzt habe ich wieder die
andere Kugel mit am Start
und noch ein Schaf ja will das Schwein
vielleicht auch noch mit oh und die
eigentliche Kuh die wir nehmen Leute das
funktioniert ja alles heute wieder nicht
wie es mir vorgestellt habe aber naja
wir gehen raus aus Minecraft tschüss
[Musik]